so I took some questions
on the Internet recently,
and, uh, some people
were upset about a show
I did back in September.
Now, that didn't
necessarily surprise me,
because we tackle
a lot of difficult subjects
on this show.
I mean, the second show we did
was about Bill Cosby's
"alleged even though I think
he really did it" raping.
That's right, I haven't
forgotten about you, (bleep).
I have not.
Still... still in here.
But we talked about...
I mean, we talked about
cops killing unarmed black kids,
the mistreatment of women,
I mean, the Flint water crisis.
I get it.
These are topics-- they're gonna
stir up some controversy.
So, anyhow, um,
so on this particular date,
we were talking about,
uh, water on Mars,
and understandably,
some people got very upset.
Uh... They thought...
they thought we disrespected
and kept interrupting our guest,
scientist Bill Nye.
And a couple commenters
even accused me
of being anti-science.
Listen, guys,
I love science, okay?
When I was a kid, I mean,
I wanted to be an astronaut.
I still wear science pajamas.
I do.
Not many guys
can pull that look off.
But I am-I am fascinated
by discoveries of all kind.
And I love it when I see kids
interested in science.
The-the last thing
I would ever want to do
is be disrespectful
of a guy who loves science.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm a blerd. I am a black nerd.
I love... Right?
I love science, I love Bill Nye.
Love me some Bill Nye.
-(cheering, applause) -I love,
uh, sci... scientific...
-Oh, my God! Oh!
-Hey.
-Hey, it's Bill Nye.
-Good to see you.
Bill Nye, everybody!
Have a seat, Bill.
Oh, my God.
It is Bill Nye.
Bill, um...
I don't know if you heard
wh-what I was just saying. Uh...
Oh, I heard you,
Larry. I heard it
-through the science
of television. -Oh.
A-And not only that,
I was... I was, uh,
-standing right over there.
-Yeah, of course, yeah. Yeah,
-yeah. Science of proximity
is what that was. -Yeah.
Okay, now, Bill,
when you were here,
I mean, you didn't feel
disrespected, did you?
Larry, Larry,
it's a comedy show.
You're thinking about this
too much.
-Let me put this
in scientific terms. -Okay.
Haters gonna hate.
You...
Larry...
you just got to let
that (bleep) go.
Hey...
those are scientific terms?
-Yes.
I am quoting Copernicus. -Oh.
"Let that (bleep) go."
He really said that.
-But... but it was in Latin.
-I know.
-It was in Latin. -He-he
said it in Latin originally,
but it translates
to "let that (bleep) go."
Okay, great.
Okay, great, I just wanted...
So we've cleared the air?
'Cause, I mean, people thought
we were interrupting you,
not letting you speak, I mean...
-Larry, there's no air to clear.
We're good. -Okay. Great.
In fact, actually, you know,
since I'm here, there is
one more thing I wanted
to mention about water on Mars.
You know, there are
-these weeping craters, and
there's also -Oh, sorry, Bill.
-ice in the polar...
-We don't have any more time.
Bill Nye, everybody!
That's all from Bill Nye!
Thanks a lot for coming, Bill!
That's so nice!
-We got to go. Bill Nye,
everybody! -That's all?
Give him a nice hand! But we got
to go! We don't have any time!
Bill Nye! So nice of him
to come out. Thanks, Bill!